hi there today we're looking at the deep
chef's deep reinforcement learning agent
for families of text-based games by
Leonard autos and Thomas Hoffman so this
is a paper about engineering an agent
for a particular family of tasks this is
different from reinforcement learning
agents that for example are just good at
one game let's say pong or or whatnot
and even I guess even things like like
Starcraft though this it kind of depends
on what do you mean by game so what are
we talking about here the following is a
text-based games where the goal is to
cook recipes right so let's just jump in
and see what goes on the game starts by
telling you you are hungry right let's
cook a delicious meal and so on so the
objective is basically this is always
the same it's fine the cookbook
read recipe that's in it then collect
all the things that are in the recipe
prepare them in certain ways that are
also specified by the recipe and then at
the end you have a meal and then you can
eat the meal and that will give you
points but since it's a text-based games
and the the input doesn't come
structured but it comes in natural text
so the game tells you for example
kitchen so basically you're in the
kitchen you are now in the kitchen I
guess you better just go and list
everything you see here you hear a noise
you spin around so that you see that the
kind of input you get from the game is
very playful has a lot of descriptive
elements sometimes it's like you see a
closed oven you make out a table then
you can see on the counter you can make
out a sliced fried red hot pepper and so
on
so it's it's it's very much no
trivial to kind of parse this in a
traditional way if you were to go about
this by simply writing an algorithm
extracting things it's very hard because
for example you might see that there's
an oven but it's a closed oven you make
out a table so this is kind of a synonym
for you see a table but you see like
there there is a table you can make out
an eighth sliced fried red hot pepper
and here it's important not only do you
need to realise that there is a red hot
pepper but also that it's state is
sliced and fried this is important
because you need all ingredients in a
certain state right you examine here you
examine the stove so there is a stove
right all these things you need to kind
of understand so if you now look there
there there is a recipe book in in here
or no there isn't a recipe you can
examine recipe I guess there is a recipe
book in that room if there is a recipe
book then you can examine the recipe and
that's the command so the the the arrows
here always indicate that that's a user
command and these you have to type
that's like the next the next thing that
your agent needs to do you can you can't
select from a predefined set of actions
you actually need to type in the things
you want to do right and these are a lot
like there are a lot of possibilities of
what you could type in even if you
restrict it to kind of what you know the
game accepts there are still so many
actions it's it's way different than for
example Atari games they always have
eight eight action like there's eight
buttons you could possibly press and
that's it and here there are like
combinatoric lee many things you can do
but you can prepare and take and all the
ingredients you don't know which
ingredients come so then yeah so here
you examine the recipe let's look at a
recipe
it says you open the recipe start
reading recipe number one here are the
ingredients read out pepper here for
right now that's just one ingredient
then there are directions so what do you
need to do slice the red out pepper fry
the red hot pepper and prepare the meal
that's better
those are the directions of the recipe
you also have this this inventory
command would tells you which you're
carrying next difficulty the inventory
is finite so he can't carry everything
at some points you have to drop things
that are unnecessary you can't just take
everything here you see the command take
red hot pepper that only works if
there's a red hot pepper in the room and
here's as you take the red hot pepper
from the counter your score has just
gone up at one point and then if you
type inventory it says you're carrying a
sliced fried red hot pepper again here
it it says the state of the ingredient
so the ingredient is the red hot pepper
and the state is sliced and fried and
then you can prepare meal and then you
can eat meal and then it says your score
has just gone up by one point and these
are the scores you collect so there are
a lot of difficulties that are actually
not shown in this example for example
there are different rooms you may have
noticed here you're in the kitchen but
there could be other rooms and you start
in a random room you also need to
navigate through the rooms the close the
doors to other rooms could be closed and
you then you need to open them and so on
you can only for example if this if this
pepper here weren't already sliced and
fried you need to find you can only
slice it if there is a knife in the room
all right you can only fry it if there
is a frying pan or an oven or a stove
sorry stove in the room so and then
you'd have to to
um notice that there is a knife if there
is no knife you'd need to take the red
out pepper bring it to a new room with a
knife and then slice it so this is
vastly difficult game and the last
difficulty is actually that in the test
set there will be ingredients that you
haven't seen during training so also
that there you your agent needs to
generalize that's why it has a family of
text-based games because the objective
all was the same to kind of cook the
recipe but the things you have to do and
the things that appear and so on those
are those change basically from episode
to episode
and the test set will be different than
the training set or kind of there will
be unseen data alright so how does this
paper go about solving this problem this
paper basically does the following and
we are going here from high level to low
level on the highest level
it's a reinforcement learning agent and
that is sort of how you would imagine an
RL agent to work so here at the end you
have a policy and the policy predicts an
action if you if you don't know what a
kind of a policy in an action things are
in RL these are the basic RL concept and
we kind of skip them here and I'll
assume everyone knows what they are but
essentially a policy specifies which
action you take next
given the current game state so the
policy is made up scores different
actions so at each step there are K
actions available and these K actions I
for said there are almost infinitely
many actions that you could take the
first difficulty and that's the and
that's the thing that actually comes in
here is to reduce all
of the possible actions that you can't
even list to just K commands so that
we'll go into that later how this is
done but basically one of the main
contributions of this paper is how do
you even specify what is reasonable what
would be reasonable to do in the current
situation and then the policy over here
only has to decide among those
reasonable actions not among all actions
so but given that you have K reasonable
commands you see here command one coming
these are embedded and then fed into gr
use which are recurrent neural networks
so for each of these commands you'll get
a 32 dimensional vector this 32
dimensional vector is here C 1 through
ck each are combined with an encoding of
the current state so these these thirty
two dimensional vector are combined with
encoding of the current state which is
256 dimensional and then fed into a
neural network that will output a
probability distribution over these
actions this is pretty classic in a deep
reinforcement learning so you have
action encoding in the state encoding
and the policy decides on that the state
encoding you'll see here is it's the
same everywhere of course because the
current games that is the current game
state this comes from this model up here
what this does is over here you have the
what you would call the state the
current observation and the current
observation is composed of many things
specifically the following eight things
so the first one is actually called
observation which is I would call all of
this the current observation if from an
RL perspective but the first is actually
observation it's whatever you saw the
big text you saw before like you are in
the kitchen it looks like this it smells
like this d turn
around and so on this would be the the
observation it's what the game engine
says at the current time step it's just
a piece of text right second missing
items third unnecessary items now these
things you might wonder okay how do I
know what what items are missing and
unnecessary these things come from
another model that this paper trains and
we'll get into that later but basically
they have a method of specifying which
items are still missing which are
unnecessary and they list those here
then description which is the output of
the last look command so in each room
you can look you can type look and then
it'll give you a description of the room
and what's in there
the previous commands this is often used
in RL either explicitly or implicitly
through a recurrent Network in order to
give the agent an idea what what
happened in the in the previous steps or
what it did so that it doesn't repeat
actions unnecessarily or so it learns to
repeat actions are necessarily required
utilities again this is a model that's
kind of trying to predict what utilities
are required to perform some actions so
as I said before if you want to slice
the red hot pepper you need a knife if
you want to fry it you need a stove
discovered locations as I said there are
different rooms you actually don't know
what rooms there are before you actually
go in in there so before you go through
a door and you reach another room so the
list of previously discovered and
visited locations is there and then the
name of the current location it is also
there so these are eight things that
make up the current observation these
eight things are just strings of text
and these eight things are each one as
you can see here these are the the eight
things from observation to location each
one are embedded and fed also into an
RNN so for each of these eight things
you'll obtain a thirty-two dimensional
vector and these are all concatenated to
make up one big 256 dimensional vector
so this 256 dimensional vector will
contain all the necessary information
about the current room what's in there
what what items are you still missing
what items do you have in your inventory
which ones are unnecessary and so on so
if you trained this correctly this 256
dimensional vector will describe the
current game state as it is relevant to
your agent like everything about it and
with every relevant information that's
in here will be encoded in this vector
now this vector isn't the final state
encoding yet what you have is you feed
this into an RNN that takes as input the
last time steps you have to imagine the
last time step already there was
observation blah blah blah this entire
thing was I'm just copying I'm just
copying this box over here so this
entire thing was already done last step
and already fed into a narnun so this
this is an Oran and that actually goes
over time and the last whatever the
output here is it will be fed to the
next step and this is a trick often done
in reinforcement learning as well that
you actually have an recurrent neural
network over the time steps so each time
step you have a certain observation you
encode it and so on you get a
description of that and then you feed
this into an RNN what the orang n can
learn to do is it can learn to react to
different not only to the current
observation but to the current
observation conditioned on the history
of previous observations so it can learn
ha before I was in this room now I am in
this new room
so I actually haven't you know taken all
the items from this room yet because I
just came into this room and so on so
the the kind of component where you are
able to look at the past and what
happened in the past is encaptured by
this RNN here so it's a fairly
complicated architecture but this here
this state encoding that is conditioned
on there also on the history then goes
into this um into here that's it that's
the vector that goes in here is combined
with each action so all of these actions
here these K actions and this is all fed
through a neural network and that will
give you the policy this is a very
complicated thing but if you look at it
it's not it's not too it's not too
difficult actually so what you'll do is
you will take your observations here
this is all observation it will be
encoded and combined with the history in
order to give you this in order to give
you an encoding of the current state on
the other hand you'll take all of the
possible commands that you could perform
right now encode each one separately
right into an embedding and then you'll
combine each one of those with this
encoding you specified previously that
you and and from that you make your
decision which action to take next and
the action here is the one that's output
is the actually take next sampled from
this policy the last thing you need is a
value network and this is just important
for reinforcement learning which tells
you from this state here
so I'm getting weird with colors here
from this state here which is the same
as this one so you'd simply transfer
this over from this state how valuable
is that what's my value of the state and
the value is if I'm in this state and I
act as I normally act what are all my
future rewards going to be combined so
it basically gives you a value of this
state you can think of this in for
example terms of Jess if you had this in
chess and then this here is it would be
a description of the chess board this HT
and the value would be how valuable is
this position for you so if you're very
much ahead in material and position and
so on this value would be very high if
you're behind this value would be very
low and this is a neural network simply
trying to predict that value so with all
of this you now have a have a good basis
to do reinforcement learning you have a
policy you have a value network and from
that you can train a neural agent and
this is done classically in an actor
critic way where you do advantage
learning here the advantage and the
policy you train waited by the advantage
then the value network you train to be
close to the reward and then you have an
entropy penalty if you don't know what
these things are the video will get bit
too long if I were to go over these
reinforcement learning concepts but
these are very standard in reinforcement
learning so you can train these you can
basically train what it does is you can
train these neural networks in absence
of label training data because you don't
know what the best action is in each
step right there's no one telling you
you just have a reward you just
sometimes you get a point and you don't
know which actions led to that so these
things will actually allow you to train
these neural networks by using in just
the reward
without knowing which exact actions were
right and wrong and that's the core of
reinforcement learning obviously all
right so the dick the core one of the
core ingredients actually is this recipe
manager and the recipe manager is a sub
model that does the following so here it
takes as an input the cookbook here and
it also takes as an input the inventory
and it outputs something like this and
this this is a this is a table
representation of what it outputs it
will output all the ingredients that you
need for the recipe whether or not this
input that this ingredient is currently
missing from your inventory and action
to perform so which actions still need
to be performed so let's look at the
following let's look at this example the
recipe tells you you need the
ingredients are a carrot a red hot
pepper and a white onion and the
inventory says you care you're carrying
a white onion and a carrot right so down
here you see aha we we do actually have
[Music]
we do actually have a carrot so it's not
missing the carrot isn't missing you
have it in your inventory the red health
pepper is missing we don't have it in
the inventory but we need it for the
recipe the white onion we need for the
recipe but it's not missing then it also
for each of the ingredients is supposed
to tell you this recipe model which of
the what you still need to perform on it
so here it says slice the carrot roast
the carrot and you simply have a carrot
it doesn't say slice the roast that
means it's not sliced
roasted so if the recipe is supposed to
output
you still need to slice and roast the
carrot here for example for the white
onion says fry the white onion and as
you can see in the inventory it says
you're carrying a fried white onion so
for the white onion you see we don't
need to do anything anymore so that the
recipe model is basically trying to to
make this table here and this table you
can see as an intermediary step in order
to do all the other things and the
difference here to a pure RL method and
this is important the difference is that
this representation this intermediate
table representation is done explicitly
so the recipe model really produces a
table like this and not just in other RL
methods people go about and make this
recipe model output some sort of you
know as I say a 200 dimensional vector
that's supposed to encompass all of this
information and that doesn't appear to
work as well like often that if you
simply train this end to end that will
not pick up on the important information
because the training signal tends to be
way too weak you have to imagine you
already have this really really big
model construction here and you're
trying to learn it you're trying to
learn it from a tiny reward signal that
you get at the end right this is very
noisy signal now if if you're now trying
to say well the inputs to these things
right this command here and we also saw
the inputs to these these depend on this
rescue model also now or whatever giant
neural network construction here and
we'll all train this end to end and
these will actually not be text these
will actually be some sort of latent
vectors that will often fail because
you're now just trying to extract
information
from too noisy of a reward signal so the
author is here to actually pretty neat
separation of that and they train this
recipe model with actually an Augmented
data set so they go to freebase and get
more food items and then they construct
a data set that resembles this and train
it in a supervised way to output tables
tables like this so this is pretty smart
and I think it's a good lesson if you
ever attempt something like this that
really really important information such
as this one if you can train it in a
supervised way as a kind of a
pre-processing step to your oral
procedure that's extremely helpful here
you can you can see how this is then
used so by combining this table that was
output from the recipe model and your
inventory and the output of this look
command you can then generate these
commands so before we said it's
important to reduce the everything you
could do which is infinite things to
everything that is reasonable to do
currently and this model here does that
so given this given that and given the
description of what's currently in the
room you can have generate these
commands and for example take knife if
you have to slice something because you
see a knife is in the room and you could
conceivably take the knife right you can
construct these commands but also since
you know right since you know what since
you know what's in your inventory and
since you know which things are still
missing you can generate commands like
take the white onion or drop the water
because you don't need the water right
so um the offers also group these things
here in this one take
high level commands which take all
required items from here simply means
take everything that's in the room that
is not in the inventory but you need it
so these things which for an RL agent it
makes sense to group these things
together because it doesn't make sense
to have them as two separate things if
you need both take both if you don't
need any what if you have an inventory
drop all of these things so that makes
sense that's a small optimization that
apparently brought some gains but the
kind of the the overarching message here
is that once you have a once you have
this information from the recipe model
you can then use it in many useful ways
in order to make life for your oral
agent easier alright so that kind of is
the entire model that's very it's quite
convoluted but basically you start with
this here this recipe manager you decide
you output this table down here which
ingredients are in the recipe
are they still missing and which actions
we need to perform you then combine it
with this information here the
information about the current room and
your inventory in order to come up with
a set of commands that are conceivable
to do here you combine these commands
with some commands that are always
available so commands that are always
available are things like look inventory
prepare meal you have that right you add
that if the recipe manager does not
output any missing and the agents
location is the kitchen so you can add
these other items and also um we're not
even gonna get into that you are at the
navigational items because there are
doors in these rooms and you need to
navigate around so they actually train
another model to here easy to detect to
detect the
actions that you could move into and
open doors for every closed door in the
room so that's another challenge that
the agent needs to overcome they have to
build an entire model to predict which
doors are there and are they close do
you need to open them so these commands
if there are doors and if you can move
through them these commands are also
added to this set of commands that are
reasonable so now we have a set of
commands that are reasonable over here
then you describe the room here you put
both into these embedding and then
finally your policy outputs an action
that's that that's the entire process
very convoluted
very big very astonishing that this
works with RL but in order to need to
get it to work you actually need to do
this supervised training and the
experimental evidence here is quite
solid in that day compared to baseline
systems that that use classic techniques
and they do some ablation over over
their individual parts and they get
second place I think in a competition
about these text-based games so that's
pretty good and that was it for me and
check it out and bye bye